Aloha, well with oral wellness here. On behalf of the whole team, we're really excited to finally be able to show you how to maximize your benefit of using oral wellness shine or remineralizing and tooth whitening powder.
Two primary purposes are intense of us making oral wellness shine. Number one, to provide you in the world, a product that we could use in the mouth to help stop existing decay, as well as protect against future decay.
As well as we wanted a secondary benefit of oral wellness shine to be able to have a gentle whitening benefit on the teeth. So oral wellness shine is a tooth powder. There are several ways to utilize it to maximize your benefit. Here's a few.
The first thing we learned about utilizing shine was that you don't want to wet your toothbrush and then dunk it in the powder. I learned this the hard way.
You know what we found? Although that's the real simple, that's the natural way you'd go about it. The problem is you're going to get more and more moisture into the powder and you're going to get halfway down that container.
It's going to turn into some gooey mess that doesn't look like it's very much fun to use. We found that it's really important to keep moisture out of this container to keep it in the powder form.
So we designed a coconut wood spoon, this cool little spoon here to be able to use as a dispenser. So I'm just going to take up a little bit of the powder and I'm going to hold my toothbrush over the shining container so that any extra powder that doesn't make it on my brush is just going to fall back into the container.
And that's ready to go. Now for added benefit, you can definitely use a dropper two or three, however you brush with your healthy mouth blend normally and you can apply the healthy mouth blend directly over the shine as well.
Now that you have your brush ready, you're going to utilize the shine and apply the shine to your teeth. Now because our teeth have vertical lines between the teeth, we do recommend that you brush vertically as you utilize the or well in the shine.
Just so you get between the teeth a little bit better than our normal micro back and forth bass brushing technique. Now that said, if you have some gum recession and some exposed root, it's still perfectly fine with or well in the shine to use the bass brushing technique along the gum line there so that you get the whitening and remineralizing benefits along the gum line as well.
Now let's talk about if you want to have a greater remineralization impact if you really want to maximize the power of utilizing shine. What we suggest is that you use multiple applications of the shine on your brush in one brushing.
The very best way we have found in our family to be able to apply shine to our toothbrush multiple times to use it in various areas of the mouth that need more remineralization support is to take a little bit of the shine, take a scoop of the shine and put it in the palm of our hand.
Now I'm not going to get any moisture in this container this way so you can multiple applications you can apply and brush and apply and brush if you're germ phobic there's nothing wrong with if you think that this is gross or you don't want to use your hand wash your hands first.
But if you don't want to use your hand nothing wrong using a small dish I did this for several months and then I finally succumbed to Susan strategy which was put in the hand and this is way easier and simpler.
It just makes a heck of a lot of sense. So another strategy you can use to get a little more remineralizing benefit to a certain area let's say you've got a certain area in your mouth that I know there's an active cavity there and you just want to put a little more power into that area.
You can just simply take a little bit of shine on a dry finger right and apply it directly to that area I'll demonstrate for example and just work it into the area and leave it be let it sit.
The formula for one that shine is going to dissolve into your saliva and hang out in that general area for some time and be able to provide greater remineralization support.
If you want to create an even longer effect you can create a little bit of paste with some shine maybe a little healthy mouth blend as well as a little bit of coconut oil I'll show you how I go about that.
For this I do use a small container and I'm going to take some shine and just put a little bit of shine in there if you like if you use our blend.
Now when you're making a paste it really does not take very much liquid at all you could just use a little tiny bit of water right now but in this case that shows you how cold it is and how high you right now is our coconut oil is a little solidified.
So just take a tiny bit of coconut oil and now you're going to make a slurry or paste out of it.
This is going to grab my brush much more easily and be I could apply it this shine paste to an area that's effective that I want greater remineralization for a longer period of time.
So if you want to focus on gentle whitening of your teeth here's a suggestion that I have.
So to accomplish a gentle whitening what we want is the dry shine on our brush.
So the most effective way to go about this would be to put some dry shine either in your hand like we showed you in a small container and you're going to dip your moistened toothbrush into the dry shine and now brush vertically on the front teeth and then apply some more shine and brush on the front teeth again.
So you're rather than brushing throughout the mouth with shine immediately you're going to utilize that dry shine and brush just your front teeth again vertically to get most of the tooth surface.
And then if you do have some receding gum some exposed roots then some bass technique along the roots to get the shine benefits along the gum line as well.
The super cool thing is as you focus on whitening your teeth unlike so many conventional whitening and bleaching products on the market you're actually going to reduce your sensitivity rather than extremely increased your sensitivity which is what most whitening products on the market do.
So those are the various strategies and ways that we've utilized shine in our mouths to help us benefit but we want to hear from you.
How have you benefited from it?
Do you like the delivery method of the coconut spoon? Do you like the flavor? Do you not like the flavor? Love it, hate it, whatever.
In a few weeks after purchasing oral on the shine you'll get an email with a survey that will ask you these questions we want to hear from you.
Together we can continue to develop and evolve oral on the shine and make it even better.
We look forward to hearing how you've benefited from utilizing oral on the shine.
By all means if you have any questions holler we're here to help.
Thank you and Aloha.
Shoot it up, you're in, you're in, you're in.
Shoot it up, you're in, you're in.
Let it shine, let it shine, let it shine.
To wrap.
Wrap.